one of the questions i get most often on
this channel is how can i get
stronger and more powerful without also
getting bigger and bulkier
it seems that people want this slim of
physique that belies their hidden
strength and power think one punch man
or bruce lee
so is this possible well the fact that
one of those examples was a real person
suggests that it probably is
but of course there are some challenges
and that's what i'm going to talk about
here
so the problem with trying to get
stronger without necessarily getting
bigger is that a lot of the
triggers the stimuli that lead to more
strength
also lead to increased hypertrophy
muscle growth they are mechanical
tension
metabolic stress and muscle damage each
of these things is used to build more
strength but it will also cause
more muscle size fortunately there are
some factors
some variables that influence strength
without having a big impact on size and
that's what we're going to focus on here
it's not just so much about the muscle
you have as it is your ability to use
that muscle efficiently
obviously there's some low hanging fruit
some easy wins that we should focus on
first
for example you want to cut away fat if
you strip back
the added layer of subcutaneous fat then
you're going to look leaner without
losing any strength
another thing we can do is to build more
tendon strength and there are several
ways you can do this i made a video on
it in the past i'll link that in the
description down below
strong attendance will contribute to
greater strength and they won't make you
look a whole lot bigger
similarly building a stronger grip will
make you stronger in nearly everything
you do
without making you look any bigger maybe
your hands will look thicker your hand
tendons and perhaps your forearms
your overall size and physique isn't
going to look like that of the hulk
there are lots of ways we can train our
strength i knew some rock climbers at
university
who had incredible gripping strength
they would do fingerboard pull-ups
with tons of weights in a backpack and
these guys were very light and slim
looking
rock climbing is also an example of
doing something that will naturally
improve
your strength to weight ratio something
that's much more interested that i'm
interested in
is a technique that was actually used by
bruce lee himself as well as another guy
who has a very slight frame but is
capable of exerting
incredible feats of strength and power
that's dennis rogers and i am of course
talking about something i've talked
about on this channel
a fair bit before that's overcoming
isometrics so overcoming isometrics are
movements
where you're pushing or pulling against
something that's too heavy for you to
move
so you might be doing a bench press but
the weight's too heavy so you're just
pushing against the bar
not making any progress likewise you
could be trying to tear a piece of rope
in half or push a
wall down there are plenty of tools you
can use to do this
you can use resistance machines are
locked in place or that have too much
weight on them
you can use tools from companies like
full worker that make a bunch of cool
things
that are great for training your
isometric strength or you can just use
your own body weight to try and lift
yourself in positions that you aren't
able to move yourself in
to get the best results i've made views
on this in the past but just quickly you
want to hold each contraction for about
six seconds using
maximum force every inch of strength you
can muster
and you want to make sure you train at
three different joint angles at least
because it only has an area of effect of
about 30 degrees the reason this works
is because you're telling your body you
need more strength than you have access
to
normally when we exert strength we're
only capable even when we try and be as
strong as possible
of utilizing around 30 of our muscle
fiber if you're an untrained individual
up to about 75 for an elite athlete and
due to henneman's size principle
the last motor units you recruit the
last bundles of muscle fibers
are actually the ones that contain the
fastest and strongest and largest muscle
fibers that would give you the my
strength so you have all of this
untapped power waiting that you can't
unlock
and you can't utilize in your movements
there are plenty of reasons for this
such as injury prevention but it also
just comes down to practice
you aren't able to coordinate that
movement well enough you're not able to
send a strong enough signal to recruit
all those muscle fibers
because you haven't practiced doing it
and that's exactly what you're doing
when you use a one rep
max or an overcoming isometric you're
pushing or pulling as hard as you can
and you're sending the strongest signal
possible and you get better at doing
this over time such that you have a
stronger link between the mind and the
muscle
using those one rep maximums will do
this and that's why that's such a great
way to build a lot of strength
but at the same time it has limitations
due to the strength curve there's only
probably one point in that movement
we are actually exerting the most force
a lot there's going to be momentum some
positions are going to be easier than
others
as you go through the repetition at the
same time the repetition itself only
takes a very short
window of time however with an
overcoming isometric you're able to hold
that contraction that maximum
contraction for as long as possible
really sending that neural drive and
practicing and strengthening
that ability to command your full
strength because there's no movement
because this is a static contraction
because the contractions are still
relatively short not causing much
metabolic build-up you're not causing
much muscle damage you don't tear much
of the muscle fiber
a lot of this happens during the
eccentric portion of a movement
you're not building more muscle you're
improving your efficiency and your
ability to command the muscle that you
already have
so that is intramuscular coordination
your ability to coordinate
different muscle fibers within a single
muscle what's just as interesting
perhaps more so
is inter-muscular coordination your
ability to utilize multiple different
muscle groups together in the right
order and with the right synchronicity
in order to exert the maximum force
through a certain
movement pattern so what i'm talking
about here is practicing technique this
is something we see all the time with
martial artists
a martial artist can deliver a much more
powerful punch than
a bodybuilder who's never thrown a punch
before because they've rehearsed that
movement over and over again unless
they're able to engage
the right muscles at the right time and
even relax the ones that would otherwise
slow them down
but this also applies to strength
movements this is what i talked about in
a previous video again
on skill acquisition and greasing the
groove pavel tatsulin talks about
strength as a skill
so you can get stronger simply by
practicing and if you want to
practice more without getting bigger
then you just spread that practice
throughout the day and this is where the
greasing the groove comes in
so pavel suggests for example if you
have a pull-up bar in your doorway then
every time you go through that door
do a few pull-ups and you'll get a bit
stronger because you'll be rehearsing
the movement pattern
you're only doing a couple you're not
going to fail you're not causing any
muscle damage so you're not going to get
bulkier from doing this you're just
going to get more efficient to do
pull-ups
and so you get stronger but if you want
to be stronger in the real world
then rehearsing pull-ups and rehearsing
curls isn't quite going to cut it
there's this trope in anime where often
the
biggest and strongest characters are
actually weaker than the
small and unusual looking characters
this is something that toriyama likes to
do
in particular at last frieza decides to
show himself
and from here he doesn't look so tough
anymore
[Music]
and at some point there'll be a scene
where the big hulking creature will
throw this massive punch or blast at the
little guy
who will just lift a finger and block it
without even seeming to move without
even seeming to need to get into a
defensive stance it can just be strong
from that angle
with seemingly no effort that's what
real wiry
unassuming power would look like and
perhaps unusually the closest
thing we have to that in real life is
farmer strength
so you might have heard of farmer
strength it's this kind of urban myth
that farmers and other manual workers
have got a whole lot of extra strength
they're surprisingly powerful despite
not necessarily practicing any kind of
strength
sport likewise you might have heard of
dad's strength this is the
notion that dads have got this kind of
unusual wiry strength you might remember
as a kid your dad grabbing your wrist
when you're being naughty and having a
seemingly unshakeable vice-like grip
where does that come from because
they're practicing movements that will
help them to build
that into muscular coordination at the
same time as strengthening tendons
and grip strength because they're moving
all throughout the day the farmer or the
manual laborer is doing
manual work and the dad is lifting his
kid on his shoulders and running around
and carrying heavy bags
because you're doing that throughout the
day you're rehearsing that movement and
strengthening yourself
but at the same time you're doing that
in standing up positions in moving
dynamic changeable positions so for an
example go and stand by a wall
stand completely straight so your legs
are side by side and your arms are down
by your side
stand about 40 centimeters away from the
wall facing it dead on
now lift one arm up to about shoulder
height and then push
against the wall as hard as you can
you'll find that even if you have a 150
kilogram bench press normally
you're probably not able to exert more
than about 30 kilograms of force here
and the reason is because you're only as
strong as the weakest link and at the
same time you have to
coordinate lots of different muscles all
at once from this mechanically
disadvantaged position
so what's actually happening is you're
stabilizing your shoulder you're
engaging your core your ex's up
dominating from yourself bending
backwards and your obliques to event
prevent yourself from twisting
you're digging through your glutes to
keep your legs straight
and even through your feet will be
digging into the ground and it's your
ability to use these muscles together
that exerts that force it's not all just
about pecs and tricep
like it is in a bench press this is how
you use your body in real life
this is what we don't really practice
but the farmer or the dad is constantly
on the move is constantly having to
practice these unusual positions
and strengthen their movement patterns
in ways that are more unpredictable like
this
imagine digging the hole for a moment
each time you dig a hole with a big
spade you're
jabbing the spade into the ground with a
lot of force the ballistic movement
then you're leveraging the spade up
which is going to feel heavy because of
that mound of dirt on the end
and then you're moving it twisting your
body to one side and dumping it over
there
then you're performing the movement
again and you're doing this again and
again throughout the day
i don't know if digging holes are
something farmers do by the way i'm i'm
not a farmer
but as you do this hole also gets deeper
so you're changing your position you're
stooping more then throughout the rest
of the day you might be carrying bales
of hay
pushing tractors wrestling pigs or
whatever else it is that farmers
probably do point is you're practicing
strength in all these different
positions
without necessarily developing size at
the same time you also build intention
strength
and grip strength which is something
else we talked about and as a result you
have this wiry
unassuming pharma strength of course you
don't have to become a professional
farmer to get that kind of strength
there are ways to incorporate this sort
of training
into your routine you can do it with
cable machines any kind of exercise
where you're standing
up and at the same time with things like
animal movements where you're just
moving your body in more dynamic ranges
of motion more unpredictable positions
training outside makes a huge difference
as well
of course any kind of movement like this
where you're exerting force from a
standing position using
more functional real world type
movements whether that's flipping a tire
or
hitting it with a sledgehammer or
throwing a medicine ball all these
things
are going to require you to use your
core and your limbs
in a more cohesive manner the way that
you use them in the real world and that
will not only
help to improve your strength and your
ability to
coordinate all those muscles together
you'll also build up those smaller
supportive muscles in your core and
other regions that don't add a lot to
your overall size
but do contribute a lot to your strength
and your performance finally we can also
combine this all with
explosive movements because we don't
just want to be strong slowly we want to
be strong
quickly using plyometric and ballistic
movements means things like
clapping push-ups clapping pull-ups
depth jumps squat jumps
and doing this improves our rate of
force development so that's the ability
to not only recruit
maximum muscle fiber but to do so
quickly but we're not actually gaining a
lot of size
because the amount of time where the
actin and myosin
filaments are engaged there's just not
enough time to cause enough muscle
damage to stimulate hypertrophy so yeah
by leaning out by changing your grip
strength by training your tendons
and by training lots of different unique
positions and practicing strength
you can become much more powerful
without necessarily adding a whole lot
of bulk
of course i don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with adding bulk as
long as it isn't causing you to slow
down as long as you keep your strength
relative to that size in fact there's
lots of advantages to hypertrophy apart
from anything else it acts as a kind of
armor when you get hit at the same time
there are many things that are easier to
train
if you allow yourself that hypertrophy
as well so don't throw the baby out with
the bathwater but as a thought
experiment i thought this was quite
interesting
the point is that a lot of the training
that focuses on strength without adding
size
is often overlooked in modern training
programs because so many people are more
interested
in aesthetics it turns out if you're
really interested in power
the many of these overlooked aspects of
training other things that you should
really
be paying more attention to so you found
this video useful interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like and
share around that helps me out immensely
comment down below and let me know
whether you're more interested in
hypertrophy
strength or a combination of the two
if you like this philosophical
alternative approach to training that's
about more than just aesthetics then
you'll probably be interested in my
ebook and training program
super functional training there i go
into all kinds of unexplored and
different aspects of training
relating to strength but also power
explosiveness mobility
endurance even brain training and then i
combine it all into a training program
right at the end
if that sounds cool then there's a link
to that in description down below and
there's a discount on whilst we're all
in lockdown
alternatively you could consider joining
the patreon group
a huge thank you to all of my current
patreons not only will you get access to
some exclusive content we also be
invited to join the
secret bioneer group on facebook where
we talk about our own training
different and unique trading methods as
well as anything interesting that we
find on the web
so we'd love to see you there i'll put a
link to that in description down below
also either way thank you so much for
watching this one subscribe if you want
more like it and i'll see you next time
bye for now
trees yeah